happy as hair in this one yes that's how
you know times pass I'm waiting the
third one he's gonna have that five
o'clock shadow yeah that's what chloë
grace moretz comes back yeah hello how
reject nation how you doing guys
denzel washington four years ago made a
movie with Antoine Fuqua frequent
collaborator now there's a sequel coming
out the equalizer - this would be
denzel's first sequel ever and this
would also be Anton fucose first sequel
ever - a movie that I don't really
remember that well from beginning to end
that jawed just watch for the first time
last night Jon do you like it yes pretty
cool nice to watch Denzel kick a whole
lot of asses in a very focused kind of
way absolutely and you know who also
takes a lot of asses our patron the day
shout out that is David Gandy I mean
this is basically the David Gandy biopic
this is what I imagine specially as when
he enters every room there's this quick
moment where he sizes up everything and
then he kills people
cuz David Gandy is a quiet guy he's an
observing guy he's an older gentleman
just like Denzel is in the movie so you
think he's not a threat
little do you know that David Gandy is
always trying to make the world a better
place
by committing violent crimes equalizing
he's equalized us by giving us DVDs a
shirt some workout gloves a guitar pick
you know so gave John a capo and a whole
bunch of things this guy is the kind of
human being that is always trying to
make the world a better place by killing
a lot of people David Gandy's a killer
and I think you all should look out when
you're up north in California David
we're on to you buddy but still stay
pledged to patreon because it helps the
channel out a lot so thank you for being
here you are equalizing everything out
that wasn't meaning to equalize let's
watch this trailer
huh he's got hair now 10 seconds it's
gonna be a lot more violent than just a
let off
[Music]
Melissa Leo's back
[Music]
oh hey shoes versus mustache I know
right I see cheated on exactly
ouch damn damn and a moving car
good
damn whoa guy likes to kill you I don't
know I this struck me as being even
bloodier for somehow like they really
made a point in this trailer to be like
look how much Bloods gonna spray on
stuff looks like denzel's found his
equal ha ha ha ha hey you know I was
wondering about that watching this
trailer cuz that's the hardest thing to
do in these movies especially as
established this guy with these
next-level skills and then especially if
you're doing another one to like
actually bring in a formidable adversary
who we're not just gonna be like okay
yeah no he's just gonna do his thing so
that's like the biggest wonder I have
for a movie like this I kind of felt
like the first equalizer is a
better-than-average action movie I don't
think it's great I think there's some
cool action sequences and denzel's
really cool it's like if they treated
taken like a film in a way yeah when it
comes to this movie what you really just
need is some more badass Denzel giving
an even more ruthless performance and
some more action sequences that are
gonna be freakin awesome
and it looks like those are the two main
ingredients that they're really
capitalizing on and that's what I'm
mainly gonna show up for there's a lot
of stuff in between the action sequences
is the first one I don't really care for
but when it gets like to the violence
I'm always really hooked into that that
all looks cool there even look seems to
be a lot more style with the action
sequences like that fight in the car I
always love a good driver taking down a
passenger type of fight scene that the
Train sequence there's a whole lot more
fight scenes it looks like the thing
with this trailer though is it feels
even more like a generic movie retired
dude partner dead now he's going out
there to get revenge the first one
already felt a little cliche but I kind
of liked that ground
level doesn't an end on a note of the
equalizer he's sending out an absence of
people can go ask for help from him I
thought it was gonna continue with that
kind of thing where he loves a hero for
hire me
yeah Hero for Hire who protects the
streets of Boston or something this is
like yeah this trailer I think this is
more like a part three or part four
territory
Brandon it's been like four years since
the last one so maybe what they need to
do to capitalize on it is go a lot
bigger yeah yeah that's the part I
really flip-flopping on is half of me
agrees with you half of me wants to see
something that is a bit more ground and
the other half is like well maybe that's
what the first movie could have used
some of you know something like much
more broad I don't know where I'm
sitting here yeah I'm kind of with you
it looks like an action thriller that
that might just have some above-average
guidance behind the camera and
performances in front of there's like a
b-movie I got a bunch of a list people
to make it feels like it arguably should
be feeling more personal because a
friend of his got killed like Melissa
Lee was barely in the first one you know
she's not like I've really thought upon
things and we're supposed to like really
care about this and feel it when I kind
of felt like the generic plot of dude
helping young prostitute out it was even
more personal for some reason than
what's being conveyed here this is just
a trailer for all I know it could be a
better movie I was kind of hoping it
would go in the direction of he finds a
more personal villain or vendetta closer
to the streets like the franchise gone
with a Hero for Hire thing that's what I
would have liked personally but like I
said the two main things badass Denzel
he looks as badass as ever
it looks like gonna be a lot more
violence and that was the best part the
first one this will be an entertaining
time I can't tell if it's a bad thing or
a good thing if it was a September
released and an August release now it's
a July release
I guess the middle of summer they must
feel like Denzel kick an ass maybe this
will draw a lot of people in like that
if anybody's familiar with the first one
that is a different Tambor at least than
a lot of the other summer fare you're
gonna get it's gonna equalize the box
office alright guys well you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell to get
five because subscribe buttons don't do
anything check us out on patreon weekly
Q&A is full like TV show reactions for
many a show and music videos as well
will love dab you come a picture on
eject today
you